obviously he wanted to play each and
every game from week one um they don't
even go till week three
but he had every intention of playing
each every game this year
it's just unfortunate that it went this
way um i don't know if this season's
over or what um but i wish he was out
there i love playing with him i love
playing for him he's the unquestioned
leader of this football team so are we
going to miss him yeah
but we got all the confidence in the
world and nick he's a phenomenal player
and we're excited to play for him
at a time when eagles coach doug
peterson is trying to keep his cards
close to the vest zach ertz his star
tight end is ripping the cards away and
throwing them on the table zach didn't
you get the memo don't talk as if carson
wentz isn't going to play they got to
keep the rams guessing until sunday
night it sure sounds like carson wentz
isn't going to play based upon those
comments from zach earth so it goes to
nick foles and there's a lot we can say
here chris and we'll jam as much as we
can in the time that we have carson once
let's start there yeah back problems
right the latest in an assortment of
injuries for a very physical quarterback
this is not good he's 25 still he turns
26 later this month this is not good to
start having back problems at this age
yeah i mean i'm not going to be sit here
and tell you i'm totally concerned but
i'm a little concerned you're right to
have those kind of issues already uh yes
you'd mentioned it i mean we've had the
knee injury he's a big man he never
gives up on a play he takes a lot of big
hits he gets twisted and contorted a lot
of different ways he scrambles he dives
he does all of that and yes to have
lower back issues which does happen with
quarterbacks a lot you see it happen
with quarterbacks and baseball players
why because you have to twist so much
and torque your body and create those
opposites between your lower half and
your upper half and we've seen a number
of quarterbacks with lower back issues
i've had them myself just because it's a
life of twisting on that front leg after
you throw the ball it leads to issues
and yes i am concerned about that
because once it does happen it continues
to pop up through life when you get
stuck in little certain situations or
banged up or twisted the wrong way and
then all of a sudden you're bothered by
it once again so uh am i gonna sit here
and say i'm totally concerned no but
it's another little red flag or [ __ ] in
the armor a little bit about carson
wentz to just go
man you know how long can he continue to
play this style of football uh and if
i'm the eagles if there's any concern
here i do hold them out the eagles are
in deep crap they're not a super bowl
team
and uh they might need to just chalk
this up
two points first of all as you were kind
of downplaying the the back issue a
little twist little torque we're playing
b-roll of violent hits being absorbed by
carson wentz yeah these are not minor
these are not minor circumstances he
finds himself in and i really would be
concerned if i were the eagles if i were
an eagles fan i mean they always have to
decide when they're going to pay this
guy how much they're going to pay him do
they pay him after this season do they
wait and see what happens with his
health status does it create issues with
wentz who is going to want his financial
reward so these are all things to be
determined in the offseason and beyond
and they're not a super bowl team now
but here comes the guy who is the
reigning super bowl mvp and nick foles
who gets a chance to make one last
impression on the free agent market you
know i was listing the upcoming class of
free agent quarterbacks over the weekend
i forgot about foles because number one
he has been out of sight and out of mind
and number two when he played early this
year he stunk yes so is he going to
stink or is he going to be the guy that
we saw in the playoffs last year i would
think that he was going to be more
towards the stinky department because
it's not just about him too it's the
rest of the team you know the one thing
i'll continue to say the defense is not
even in the same stratosphere as last
year they had one of the best run
offenses in football this year they
can't run worth a damn okay and yes i
i would i would you know err on stinky
too because of the other fact mike of we
know the rams are really good and you
have to go out there across the country
and play them after they played their
worst game of their year and uh they're
gonna be pissed off and mad about the
way they played in chicago let alone
that they have weapons galore and the
eagles are not as good at rushing the
passer they have no coverage guys in the
back end so all those things lead me to
believe that the eagles were in deep
crap sunday night no matter what whether
it was carson wentz nick foles or
superman
well that i mean that's the problem this
eagles team just has not been anything
close to what we saw last year the magic
isn't there everything lined up for them
right last year including in the
playoffs look i i said yesterday that
that nick foles was basically the
football equivalent of slumdog
millionaire in the postseason where
every break went his way he was in the
right place at the right time just
everything clicked and everything worked
and and i'm still impressed by what he
accomplished but
it feels like it was a very small
self-contained sliver of history that
isn't going to be duplicated that
doesn't make him a guy who's going to go
somewhere else and be a great
quarterback we saw him go somewhere else
after he had a great initial run in
philly he went to the rams and it was
bad he went to the chiefs and he had a
little opening there to take the job
away from alex smith right and it and it
did not go well right and it didn't go
well earlier this year his stats really
were abysmal even though they went one
and one in the two games he started and
and if i'm nick falls i mean look i see
this as an opportunity to really stake
my claim for a nice contract on the open
market but i just don't think he's going
to be able to do it and maybe that's
what he wants us to think because we
were saying this a year ago i don't
think he's going to be able to do it and
the next thing you know he's holding the
lombardi trophy yeah i i hear you but
but i just would be shocked if that were
the case i mean last year like you said
it was just a different team they could
play a different style of football they
could kind of impose their physical will
on you you know one of the reasons
carson wentz is hurt is because carson
wentz has to do everything for that
offense right now i mean who scares you
on the eagles the eagles don't have one
guy that when the ball gets in their
hand you go oh gosh he could go to the
house they don't have one guy that is at
the receiver position where you go whoa
the defense better watch out for him or
he is going to tear them apart all day
deep down the field zach ertz is the
go-to guy we know he kind of works the
middle of the field and he's a really
good football player but that's the
number one issue with carson wentz i
mean i even heard on some of the radio
clips that we played at the start of the
seven o'clock hour hour you know the
radio people in philly go oh he's
holding the ball too long well i watched
the film of the cowboys game there
wasn't four people open the whole game
he had to hold the ball or he was just
gonna get sacked or throw interceptions
or whatever so they're just handicapped
on the offensive side of the ball right
now and i just can't imagine that folz
goes out there and is too successful
yeah look they haven't had jay ajayi for
most of the season he was going to be
the home run hitter in the running game
he's due to become a free agent they
just got darren sproles back recently
he's retiring after the season yeah boy
i i you know le'veon bell hitting the
open market i keep thinking the jets are
going to be the team that makes a run on
it but maybe the eagles should give that
some consideration as well and delay
paying carson wentz by a year or two and
explain to wentz we have to wait to pay
you because we have to pay le'veon bell
for now and maybe that is the thing that
would get once to say i'm fine with wade
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports